hello everybody hope that you are good
today is Monday and that means that is
the start of a new trading week which is
exciting so there are a couple of things
that I want to talk about but I'm going
to try to keep this video nice and short
maybe around 10 minutes um we're going
to be talking about a few things the
first thing that I want to mention is of
course this range this range if you
remember the range lows were around here
the last time we were talking about it
but I think on Friday we
extended to this uh range lows which uh
makes a lot of sense and that's why we
could identify the possibility of this
sweep of the lows and then a pump to 52k
because we had this week over here if
you guys remember that was on Friday I'm
pretty sure that some people that follow
my videos uh are possibly talking about
the Monday false move the Monday false
move so you guys understand is a move
that is false that happens usually right
at the start of the week that's what we
say Monday but it can also happen over
the weekend because the trading week
finishes on Friday evening right so the
the start of the week is when that
trading week finishes usually happens on
Sunday evening or Monday but this false
move can also happen over the weekend
because the weekend is really the start
of the new trading week all right so um
some people might be talking about this
drop today being the bond is FSE Smo
because today is Monday so they think
okay Monday Monday for Smo but the
people that really understand what I
what I mean also know that this move can
happen over the weekend all right and if
you notice in my opinion this pump here
was the first move we're going to talk
about why okay the first thing that I
want to say and I want you to try to
understand this is why would Bitcoin
move up
$1,400 because if you notice that's from
50,600 to 52,000 that's $1,400 move why
would Bitcoin move that much over the
weekend when the institutions are not
playing because I mean take the hongor
exchange Wall Street go go out in your
city and try to exchange some money on
Saturday or on Sunday you're going to
get the same rate because the exchanges
are having the week off they are not
working so the same happens with Bitcoin
if the big players are not playing so
that means that there is low liquidity
in the chart why would Bitcoin not range
why would Bitcoin move up or down that
high because yes I mean 1,400 is qu a
big move that's a almost a 3% move two
70% move okay that's a big move for the
weekend so in my opinion that's a false
move that's the fa justification it
doesn't make sense low liquidity Big
Move false it has to be false and the
second justification is that when that
happens when we don't have consolidation
over the weekend and instead we have a
big move up or a big move down that
creates a gap in the market okay now you
can go to this chart it's called Bitcoin
Futures go to the 15 minutes time frame
and you're going to notice that this
weekend we created this massive Gap
these gaps tend to get retraced straight
away the next week now in the Bitcoin
soon update I was talking about the the
idea that in my opinion it was more
likely to leave this uh this Gap for
later on in the week but you can see how
we filed the stay away okay and this is
this happens okay go back to
bitcoin for our time
frame so what I was saying yesterday is
that I was I wanted to favor Longs why
well because we have this sweep of the
lows and when we see a sweep of the lows
then the next natural Target is going to
be the range highs it also happens in
the opposite way look at this do you
have here resistance sweep of the highs
drop okay okay happens again sweep of
the highs of the range that's really
that's really the first sweep of the
highs of this range because would have
really a range here developed yet but
this is a sweep of the highs you go to
the lows to the range lows sweep of the
lows I think you should go to the range
highs that's how the structure moves
okay so I said that yesterday uh I was
not going to jump into any position
because I always like to wait on till
Monday I thought that because we saw
this s of the high of the lows it was
likely to go to the range SI have a
little retrace but instead of happening
is that we actually go a deeper retrace
we fill the whole Gap CME Gap that I've
just shown you and now
really is we could see the real move of
the week because that imbalance that was
created over the weekend has been
retrace now so what was the false move
think about it please was the false move
the retrace of the imbalance or was the
false move the imbalance itself well to
me is clear it was the imbalance itself
and today we only retraced it okay so
now we can start to see the real move of
the
week it's difficult to tell because
we're going to go to h capital in a
moment but it's a mess the chart is a
mess well I'm going to show you right
now let's go h capital liquidation hit
map 7 Days time frame check this out
it's a real mess okay I don't remember
seeing
this uh for a long time I don't even
remember when I saw this last time or if
I ever seen something like this 7 Days
time frame okay this is not the 12 hours
time frame 7 Days time frame there is
loads of liquidity to the downside all
the way to
50,000 but hey there is also L liquidity
to the upside all the way to
53,000 so what is going to happen next
when is there more liquidity to Target
for the next move it's not clear guys at
least for now we canot make a projection
or an idea based on the liquidations
because there is justification to attack
both s sites the same okay so I wouldn't
take this liquidity map into
consideration for what's more likely to
happen but I will take it into
consideration for potential targets
53,000 even a bit higher 53,000 200 or
150 actually and to the downside say
50,000
when there could be some support all
right now in the one month time frame I
don't think I've checked this
yesterday let me have a
look it's not clear NE okay you have
some liquidity but it's really really
far away okay that's like a a 20% drop
too far away to take any conclusions I'm
a day trader I'm trading level by level
I care I I only care at the moment if
you're going to go to 50,000 or 53,000 I
don't care about 45 and much less about
41,000 right so not taking that into
consideration and now in the liquidation
levels today I broke the rule of the
channel because usually it's the it's
first the liquidation levels but I was
too excited to show you the liquidation
hit
map liquidation levels Max
liquidity Delta very neutral back to
zero nothing no information from here
and the spikes I can see more spikes to
the upside and they take me
to 52,0
400 and
53,1 100 so those are the main liquidity
levels in the chart right now would say
Okay liquidation level says more options
or more probabilities more chances for
upsite but it's not very clear guys so
take this with a pinch of
salt we're back at the chart and I'm
going to try to tell you what I think um
or at least how I'm going to uh trade
this the first thing that I want to tell
you is that we have to be very careful
trading today because you can see how
the price action is very
choppy it's not very clear what's going
to happen next I'm going to favor Longs
I said that also in in the sunnday
update yesterday uh for the single
reason that we've seen this sweep of the
lows and that tells me that if they
wanted to go low One Sweep more liquid
in that move they could have done it
okay they could have jumped from here to
50,000 and they didn't so that means
that for now they are happy with the
liquidity that they've taken here that's
what I think okay that's what we've seen
that sweep of the of the lows then the
retest of the range lows as support you
can see there that was the entry if you
would have taken this I didn't because I
don't touch Bitcoin on the weekend I
focused on Solana that by the way we a
very cool trade here
there because in here we had the daily
50 ma we can check this
out where is it in here daily 50 ma
tested a support I posted in this candle
that I was entering along at well that I
entered along at 99 99 to
80 and that my Target
was4 because I saw uh it's not really a
long week but to me
for a weekend it would be a good Target
okay and that was a 50 uh 1004 we got to
100 for the 80 and then boom drop to the
back to the entry so that was a very
good trade to be honest I'm very happy
with that 5% pump on a Saturday I take
that anyway back to bitcoin then I want
to talk about this we have this sweep of
the lows which tells me that they've
already taken all the liquidity to the
down that they wanted so the next
natural move is the range highs that's
52,500 that's going to be
uh I'm not sure if that's going to be my
take profits I think it's going to be my
first take profits but it's going to be
a small take profits because I think the
area that I'm looking to take more
profits is really above the range highs
okay it's more into this area that's the
area where I'm going to close to my
position and that's between 53,1 100 and
5 2,850 something like that okay that's
more the area that I'm going to Target
not this but because it's the Range High
and we can see a rejection that's an
area where I'm going to take my first
take profits
okay anyway how I'm going to enter this
well I'm not in a trade right now um so
I have to try to find an entry the CME
Gap has been fully retraced which tells
me that there might not be more reason
to drop and if we drop and we go again
to the range lows then it's very likely
that we actually break through and go to
50,000 finally okay but because I think
that that's less likely what I'm going
to do is I'm going to wait for this
candle to close it closes in 2 hour so
it's going to
close uh into the New York session and
then if it close above the 4H hour 50ma
then a good entry would
be the retest that's your entry and then
Target 52,500 first Target okay
something like that very simple trade I
don't want to put much money into
Bitcoin right now I'm going to go with
very small size very low risk and not
putting much money into it okay I'm
going to update through through Twitter
but I wanted to push this video to
explain why I think that the the M false
move was not this drop why was this pump
and also why I'm still faing Longs okay
in the day trading I do think that it's
likely that in high time
frame we could start to retrace some of
these levels here to the downside but I
don't want to really jump into those
conclusions yet I want to see first how
this range continues to develop I would
like to
see a new wave to the upsite and then
based on that reaction I can Define what
is going to happen or what is more like
it to happen in my opinion next okay in
the high time frame if I want to have a
breakout then I would need to see some
consolidation Above This level
here yeah above this level 52,800 if I
see consolidation here that means that
we're going to see a
breakout but if we do a new sweep of the
of the highs something like this get
back inside the range then I'm sorting
this again the same as I did here and we
want into the range lows okay um the
same take profits at the range lows and
save some in case we actually break down
so that's kind of like my high time
frame view but not very detailed because
I don't want to get into conclusions I'm
going todate you today through Twitter
this evening if I take any position for
Bitcoin so I hope that video was clear
also in case you haven't seen it um I've
open a slots for the course you have the
link in the description I think we've
already sld out 60 slots 60 60 spaces
out of 80 so there will be around 20
spaces left only uh do you have the link
in the description it starts the 4th of
March it starts next week next Monday so
if you're interested have a look and get
some information in the website thank
you so much for watching guys and I'll
see you soon